グループディスカッションって僕も無理なんすよね…
何人か人いると僕絶対発言とかしないタイプの人間だったので
人が多いとキツイよね…
頑張って下さい！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです！
なんかね、
お店に行くと売れ残っていたので買ってあげました。
こちら！
「バイオニックバード」
見て下さいこの無垢な顔。
助けてあげるしかねぇと思ったわけですよ。
タッチ　ザ 　スカイ
で、見て下さい！
元々の価格、何と税込で17,280円
それが何と値下げされて6,945円！
フワァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァン
可愛そうー（泣）
どうした？
お前何があった？
そんなに何かヤバそうなアレじゃないと思うんですけど
ただ説明書がもうなんか
誰かが印刷したみたいなものが付いてて
すげぇ
すげぇよ
訳分かんねぇよ
ヤベェヤベェ
待って何でこんな説明書付いてんの
中に入ってないの？
え？…これ英語じゃないな。
多分これフランス語ですね。
すみません、おおよそでいきます。
えぇ`:@:$#△○%…
おおお！
この子
とりあえず開けて見ましょう。
すごいですね
なんか卵が充電器らしいんですよ。
どうやってこれで充電するんだろうね
変なの
とりあえず　何やかんや
多分、充電しないと始まらないやつなんで
卵とりあえず充電して見ます。
え、これ大丈夫？
なんか待って
ちゃっちい　ちゃっちい
え待ってちゃっちくね？これ大丈夫か？
はい一応出来ました。
いや、別に全然いいんですけど、
これで１万７千円はちょっとさすがに
うぉ！
振り向く速度だけすごい。
速い…
卵の上に乗って充電できるていうのは凄いですよね。
とりあえずアプリをインストールします。
絶対これだ。
もうアプリの顔見たらすぐわかる。
なるほど
なんか操作は結構シンプルっぽいっすね。
はい、と言う訳で充電完了しました。
ここに多分鳥さんを置くと
おい
きた！
はい、これで今充電できてると思います。
点滅中が多分充電だったんで
これでもう待つに待つしかないですね。
では待ちましょう。
はい、と言う訳で充電が無事完了しました。
これをスマホで操作しながら飛ばせるらしいんですけれども、
僕にはそうは思えません。
てかなんか家の中でも出来るって言うのがありがたいですよね。
さあ来い
おっ、来た！
名前を決めるんだ、鳥の。
よし、お前の名前は今日から
「ジミー」だ。
これでもう操作できるのかな？
え、マジでこれもう出来んのかな？
ちょっとジミー飛ばしてみます！
いける？
あ、あ、おいおいおい！
ハハッ（笑）
ちょっと待ってw
はい、いいですか〜
ってことはこれもっと高度上げれば
飛ばないんかーーーーーーーい！
何で？
ハハッ　待ってw…
お前ほんと飛ぶ気ないでしょ？
何で？これ持ってた方が良いのかなぁ。
持ってたら飛ぶとかないかなぁ。
おいおい、死にかけのセミかよ。
待って下さい…。
何でだろうなぁ。
何か原因があって飛ばないんだと思います。
どこだろう
頑張れジミー！
飛べ！
こりゃダメだ…。
外いきます！
はい、と言う訳でちょっと室内だとジミー飛ばなかったんで
外で飛ばしてみます。
これで飛ばなかったらもう終わりですからね。
いきます
はい！
おー待ってどこいった？
いきます
行け！
おーい！
はい！
きた！
待ってどこまでいく？
ジミー！
ジミー！ジミー！ジミー！
いけ！
ぬぉ〜ん ビックリした…
待って！
やばい、それはやばい。